[Music]
you work at the college library you're
in the middle of a quiet afternoon when
suddenly a shipment of 1,280 different
books arrives the books have been
dropped off in one long straight line
but they're all out of order and the
automatic sorting system is broken to
make matters worse classes start
tomorrow which means that first thing in
the morning students will show up in
droves looking for these books how can
you get them all sorted in time one way
would be to start at one end of the line
with the first pair of books if the
first two books are in order then leave
them as they are otherwise swap them
then look at the second and third books
repeat the process and continue until
you reach the end of the line at some
point you'll come across the book that
should be last and keep swapping it with
every subsequent book moving it down the
line until it reaches the end where it
belongs then start from the beginning
and repeat the process to get the
second-to-last book in its proper place
and keep going until all books are
sorted this approach is called bubble
sort it's simple but slow you'd make one
thousand two hundred and seventy nine
comparisons in the first round then one
thousand two hundred and seventy eight
and so on adding up to eight hundred
eighteen thousand five hundred and sixty
comparisons if each took just one second
this process would take over nine days a
second strategy would be to start by
sorting just the first two books then
take the third book and compare it with
the book in the second spot if it
belongs before the second book swap them
then compare it with the book in the
first spot and swap again if needed
now you've sorted the first three books
keep adding one book at a time to this
sorted sub line comparing and swapping
the new book with the one before it
until it's correctly placed among the
books sorted so far this is called
insertion sort unlike bubble sort
it usually doesn't require comparing
every pair of books on average we'd
expect to only need to compare each book
to half of the books that came before it
in that case the total number of
comparisons would be four hundred and
nine thousand two hundred and eighty
taking almost five days you're still
doing way too many comparisons here's a
better idea first pick a random book
call it the partition and compare it to
every other book then divide the line by
placing all the books that come before
the partition on its left and all the
ones that come after it on its right
you've just saved loads of time by not
having to compare any of the books on
the left to any of the ones on the right
ever again
now looking only at the books on the
left you can again pick a random
partition book and separate those books
that come before it from those that come
after it you can keep creating sub
partitions like this until you have a
bunch of small sub lines each of which
you'd sort quickly using another
strategy like insertion sort each round
of partitioning requires about one
thousand two hundred and eighty
comparisons if your partitions are
pretty balanced dividing the books into
128 sub lines of ten would take about
seven rounds or eight thousand nine
hundred and sixty Seconds sorting these
sub lines would add about twenty-two
seconds each all in all this method
known as quicksort could sort the books
in under three and a half hours but
there's a catch your partitions could
end up lopsided saving no time at all
luckily this rarely happens that's why
quicksort is one of the most efficient
strategies used by programmers today
they use it for things like sorting
items in an online store by price or
creating a list of all the gas stations
close to a given location sorted by
distance in your case you're done quick
sorting with time to spare
just another high-stakes day in the
library
[Music]